amanda is in Georgia hey Amanda
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show how can
Doctor John and I help all right thank
you can you hear me okay
we can't you bet okay great well just at
a high level my husband
posed sort of an ultimatum to me back in
December which was you know you say here
in Atlanta and figure out how to make
your own way or move with me to
Chattanooga which is about a hundred
miles away
we've been married over nine years we
have the seven-year-old daughter I'm a
contractor and I don't know if I'm going
to continue on past June I but now I'm
interviewing for other roles like at CDC
and Georgia Pacific and my husband who's
educated just kind of wants to leave his
job and pivot in his career and figure
out what he wants to do but he feels
like just getting out of the city and
moving to Tennessee is better because
his parents have passed on they've left
them five paid off properties one is
like a main house that's you saying we
could live in there's four rental
properties and he just wants to kind of
be debt-free and move away and and I'm
scared to death because my life and my
career and my opportunities for job
opportunities are here in Atlanta so I
lost a lot of sleep over this over the
past few months thank you for taking my
call so how's your how's your marriage
you know the most if I feel like the
most important thing home is to have it
to be debt-free and he only have one
debt which is a $42,000 did not loan but
you know I'm not talking about you I'm
not talking about that okay there's
something not whole here yeah
people don't just come in and go I'm
gonna leave if you want to come with me
that'll be great
this doesn't happen in a good marriage
or when they do they've read yeah that's
the end of the road for them that's the
end of the line is it
that kind of ultimatum or is it more of
an ingest hey let's just do this I'm
trying to get it from you is your
marriage in real trouble oh you know you
know you know not might be is your
marriage in real trouble yeah I would
say it is we've tried to get counseling
but my husband just wants to leave and
he's like fend for yourself unless you
move out here with me yeah this doesn't
have anything to do with real estate
it's it's cool that you got five paid
off probably doesn't even have anything
to do with him being willing to leave
willing belief it's got the dairies
wanting to leave you yeah there's a
disconnect between the two of you that's
way bigger than a real estate and do you
want to stay married do you like do you
want to stay married to him do you love
this guy I love him and I would have
been willing to consider things that he
had more of a strategy and other than
I'm quitting my job and moving there and
just you know yeah I don't I don't with
all due respect Amanda I don't think
you're hearing what Dave and I are
saying this you're talking about
strategies and plans and what's it going
to be like to be a landlord versus I'm
applying for a new job that's not what
we're talking about like your marriage
is on fire and somebody who has been
married to you for the better part of a
decade has said I've found another train
now and it's not a her that you know of
but it's an it's an opportunity I'm out
you're welcome to get on the train if
you want but I'm out that is not a
real-estate issue that is a are we gonna
make this are we gonna make continue to
make a go with this and that's I'm
asking you are you interested in your
marriage do you still love this emoto's
he doesn't propose an ultimatum like
this unless the marriage has degraded
far enough that his vision of his life
in Chattanooga is better than being
married to you otherwise you don't throw
an ultimatum up like that because here's
the thing let's say that you were dumb
enough to go okay if that's the case the
only way we can stay married is I'll go
then guess what
when you get up there you're still
married to the exact same guy that was
willing to walk away from you
the worst part about moving is that you
go with you
and that was that would just be weird so
the problem in in this whole discussion
is not whether it's correct to stay in
Atlanta with your career aspirations and
those to be respected and heard by him
and it's not whether it's whether his
goals are being debt-free and taking the
family inheritance he's gotten and
starting a new life in Tennessee versus
Atlanta it is correct neither one of
those are wrong the ultimatum is what's
wrong
and quite honestly your indifference to
the ultimatum yeah like you didn't hear
it in here what it meant no I believe me
I cried myself to sleep many nights so I
just I was I'm just at a point where I'm
like well maybe it makes sense but with
them and it might it might I've made the
same concession I lived in Houston which
is similar to Atlanta I loved it and
then we had an opportunity my wife asked
if I was interested in moving to a city
similar to Chattanooga in Texas and we
had a discussion about it we did it as a
team and then we moved together as a
team and so what I'm saying to you is
you've gotta decide if you want to stay
in this marriage number one number two
you got to sit down with your husband
and I'm telling you right now it's 10x
what you think it is the journey back to
each other is going to be long and
you've got to Rica Munich 8 reconnect
and get with a professional to help you
to help you walk alongside each other
back together and and the reason is is
that no one does an ultimatum like this
unless it's really bad already the
ultimatum is not an indication of he
wants to go to Chattanooga it's an
indication of he doesn't care whether
you go or not that's what's scary here
and and if you hear your voice if you
hear in your heart I'd rather stay in
Atlanta like I want him to go then
that's that's a conversation you gotta
have with yourself and with your
counseling with your husband and if you
say I'm willing to drop all of this and
go there then that tells me you still
have some fire in your belly about your
marriage and you need to sit down and
look him in the eye and say let's make
this right and let's make this whole
because he doesn't know I don't I don't
want to go to
Chattanooga with this in this condition
that it's saying absolutely not you got
to fix this marriage before you'd make
the commitment to go you can't just go
to go along go to go along he's not
going to work
because what's broken will still be
broken when you do that because you know
I can't tell you man if if this happened
in my house you know either way either
one of us would go you gotta be kidding
really you really think you're that
important don't you you know I mean that
would not go well no and but it's an
indication that it already isn't going
right but the beauty is time and time
and time and time again couples face
these crossroads and they both let the
let their air out of it alone so and
they look each other and say let's do
this let's reconnect I'm fine if you
live in Atlanta or Chattanooga as long
as you heal your marriage first there
you go and your marriage is probably
worth it oh it's worth feeling but this
is the fire alarm that's not going off
okay I don't think I got where I wanted
to go completely on that last call I I
somehow didn't get the line there and I
know I didn't connect the light bulb
never went on over her head I know that
so let's kind of walk that through from
a relationship IQ perspective yeah okay
he comes in and says I'm going to
Chattanooga
you wanna come fine you don't want to
come fine just let me know but I'm
leaving so let's back up even before
that his parents died right okay so
that's the family homes up there it's
debt-free he has a desire to be dead
it's got five family homes he's been
living in a city maybe working with
living in a place he doesn't want to to
support her dreams livestreams I'm
making up a narrative here okay but he's
got a trauma and then there's something
problem I activate something falls from
the sky and he has a decision now you
can say it where he says I've been in
this a decade
I see the trajectory on this thing I've
got a chance to do something different
which is a common seven to 10-year
marriage each right that's gonna call it
and add to that a trauma that activates
it there you go
okay but even with that even with the
trauma and even with the standard itch
it's all it's often a light bulb right
it's
but but even with that he doesn't
suddenly come to the world and that's
where the the it uses a lot on me
because he you know in other words at
some point he was trying to talk to her
and she wasn't no she just wanting to
listen there's the in and he found out
he finally reached the end of that and
this went well
look now a train showed up to take him
out of town no yeah but I mean it's it's
the communication was broken before we
got to the ultimatum way before the
ultimatum way way before ache down in
their relationship way before it break
down a trust because I can't imagine
doing that Sharon I have made a lot of
very painful and difficult decisions
that the other one didn't want to do
necessarily and it just took a while to
get there but there was always a respect
of the other person's viewpoint there
was always a connectivity a sense of
dignity and even when we were fighting
about it that was there because there's
an underlying foundation that we may
disagree but he's not trying to hurt me
or he's not trying to bury me or she's
trying to you know but she's not gonna
leave sounded like that that a little
bit like one possible narrative to go
with you then it would match with yours
actually is that he's been saying for
years I want to get out of debt and
she's been sitting on the student loan
and wouldn't talk about it well I like
living in the city he's been saying I
hate Atlanta I want to get out of here
and she'd been going I don't hate it
mm-hmm and he's been going you know and
so he's not hurt mm-hmm in a sense and
he went well you're not listening to me
sorry I'm leaving by the way right and
going to Chattanooga and but the point
is it's not the debt free thing it's not
the inheritance that caused this it's
not even you know the difference in size
and lifestyle between Chattanooga and
Atlanta which is substantial it's a
splinter in a relationship that's there
Opie relationship that has turned into a
gulf yeah and then she's sitting there
going I don't think I won't leave my job
and we could even get her to talk about
the relationship being screwed up well
and and I thought about that over the
break too and I I want to give her grace
and understand there is a point when
when you are blindsided or you are
unaware
and you go into fix-it mode right your
brain goes to math you go to fight
flight or freeze and you're frozen
you're just trying to solve a math
problem right now and that's what I was
trying to do is get her out of a math
problem and say whoa whoa whoa your
sidewalk that you're walking on doesn't
exist anymore and if you don't want it
to that's one thing if you do stop
talking about money don't talk about
getting out of debt and life in Atlanta
for Chattanooga career it's not the guy
that you married that you said forever
to with a seven-year-old kid is yelling
through a megaphone at you I'm out and
you're welcome to come and that's the
heartbreaking part of that for me that's
when you put all your career stuff down
and all of your dreams and ambition and
you look somebody in the eye and you
hold their hands and say what happened
where are we and let's let's redo this
reconnect this thing yeah and you really
get in some pretty intensive marriage
counselor you got to have somebody at
this point you got somebody walk along
with you and then the career stuff and
the weird one can have that stuff back
on the light but right now it's gotta be
calling the plate off absolutely cause
you get that plate you you know if you
keep moving that food around it's not
going anywhere right so you can just
discuss this crap you know it's as if
you know well he listens Dave Ramsey and
he wants to get out of debt worse and he
must be married to me you still won't be
married to you and I think that anytime
somebody blames Dave Ramsey or she
didn't but she blamed his desire to get
out of debt and that's that's like again
going back to the first caller of the
day that's like yelling at the the fire
alarm to stop yelling sellout and not
realize the kitchens on fire and there's
smoke everywhere right it's just so
interesting mmm so interesting as we
talked to so many on here that are you
know how do I get my spouse involved how
do I get my spouse on board which is a
much healthier question oh you know it's
like yeah I really want to do this and I
really want them to come with me and I'm
not threatening to go without them and
almost hearing that question how do I
get them on board a I won't do this if
it's gonna cause that one all right I
can't go without that and I always tell
them you shouldn't go without them
because it's not gonna work anyway gonna
work anyway yeah so very interesting